Mein Fisch hat zwei Flossen.
Sie weiss, dass ich das gesehen habe. Ditz! Ditz! Ditz! Ditz! Sie weiss, dass ich das gesehen habe. Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu einer Ausgabe von Das Podcast UFO. Schön, dass er mit dabei sitzt. Stefan Slork. Sorry, ich habe hier Slork stehen. Es fühlt sich falsch an. Es ist nicht mehr aktuell. Sorry, ich habe hier noch Slork stehen. Ja, es ist die Abkürzung von Slorkshire. Ach so, sorry, ich habe mich ein bisschen vorbereitet auf die heutige Folge. Ich fand die letzten vier Folgen so ein bisschen schlampig, irgendwie so ein bisschen unkoordiniert. Das ist interessant, weil auch ich habe mich vorbereitet. Ach wirklich? Wollen wir auf der gedachten Null sagen, worauf wir uns vorbereitet haben? Okay, drei, zwei, eins, Rotkehlchen. Ach so, ich dachte, weil ich hatte hier Stefan Slog, Autodieb. Stimmt das denn? Ich habe das recherchiert, ich habe so ein bisschen ... Wie gesagt, das ist eine starke Vergangenheit, über die ich jetzt nicht unbedingt ... Ach so, ich war ja dann auch im Knast für zwei Jahre. Dann ist es auch gut, damit ist das Thema ja auch gegessen. Okay, das habe ich gar nicht gefunden. Wieso, das ist das Erste, was man findet. Ich dachte vielleicht so ein bisschen, wie kommt man ins Auto rein und dann, also, bist du, mit diesem Draht.
Und du warst damals Stefan Slog, oder war das, war das so eine Art Deckname, oder was?
Ja, Slogschauer.
Okay, aber wie ist das, wenn dann, also die, ist schon mal jemand hinter dir hergerannt, während du im Auto dann gefahren bist, oder wie, also die Person, der du das Auto klaust, du, wenn du nicht drüber reden musst, musst du nicht drüber reden. Ich hatte es mir einfach aufgeschrieben. Hattest du Kontakt mit den Opfern, denen du das Auto geklaut hast? Gab es da Zusammenstöße? Ja, aber die können ja nicht gut hinter mir her, weil ich habe ja deren Auto dann. Okay, und die rennen und du fährst mit dem Auto? Die rennen erst, ich fahr, fahr, fahr und dann müssen die schnell aufgeben. Okay, und du schaltest dann auch so, dass die nicht hinterherkommen? Ja, also ich schalte so, dass man jemanden halt schaltet. Okay, also zum Beispiel, wenn du im ersten Gang bist, sagen wir mal. Findest du, dass du dich gut vorbereitet hast auf diese... Nur kurze Zwischenfrage. Also ich habe... Ich hatte nicht viel Zeit, leider. Aber ich habe... Also... Krass, wow. Und dann hast du aber aufgehört mit Autodiebstahl, oder... Ja, genau, weil sie mich dann geschnappt haben. Wer hat sich geschnappt? Die Polizei. Und die Polizei ist hinter ihnen hergerannt? Nein, nicht gerannt, die sind gefahren. Die haben gesehen... Und du bist gerannt. Das Nummernschild wurde sich aufgeschrieben von Leuten, die gesehen haben, ah, jetzt geklaut. Und dann haben die gesagt, ja, hier alle Streifenwagen in der Nähe, achtet auf, haha für Hamburg, BZ 312 oder so. Ach krass, daran erinnern Sie sich noch, an das Nummernschild Na klar, na klar. Was war das für ein Auto? Ein Honda Civic.
Krass. Ja, es war ein schickes Auto, schnell auch, schnell. Nicht schnell genug anscheinend. Nicht schnell genug. Nee, die haben mich dann auch ganz gut so ... Es gab einen Verfolgungszirk durch ganz Hamburg. Ach was, wirklich? Durch den Verkehr, also konnte man da gut schnell fahren? Wenn ich durch Hamburg fahre, ist es eher so Stop and Go-mäßig, dann wäre es aufstopft. Es war verstopft, weil das Blaulicht im Rückspiegel sießen und das Adrenalin hast, dann bin ich vorbei. An dem Stau vorbei, über die Grünfläche oder gegen Faber. Genau, erst war es Grünfläche, dann über die Gegenverband ein bisschen und dann. Wahnsinn. Ja, es war nicht so crazy, es war crazy, es hätte viel mehr passieren können, also bin ich auch nicht stolz drauf. Ja, ja, ja, krass. Aber ich habe, ähm, ich kann jetzt keine Zahlen sagen, aber ich habe natürlich, ich war sehr erfolgreich und sehr gut in den ... Wie viele Autos hast du ungefähr, also in Dutzend, sagst du in Dutzend, ein Dutzend? Okay, in Dutzend kann ich sagen, weil niemand weiß genau, was das ist. Drei Dutzend. Drei Dutzend, wow. Bis ich geschnappt wurde. Bis du geschnappt wurdest, krass. Das ist eine halbe, drei Dutzend ist eine halbe Masse. Ja, halbe, ja. Wahnsinn, was, also krass, weil wir machen jetzt den Podcast schon so lange, aber den Teil deines Lebens kannte ich noch gar nicht. Wenn man mal so ein bisschen recherchiert, das lohnt sich total. Du hast mich kennengelernt, da bin ich gerade rausgekommen.
Wirklich?
Ja, aus dem Bau.
Ach krass.
Komm, du warst so ein ganz zahmer, wirklich fast schon wirklich zu weicher, also fast gar nicht aufrecht stehen können, der Jüngling.
Also ich hätte gar nicht gedacht, dass du jetzt so eine krasse Verbrecherkarriere hinter dir hast irgendwie.
Wo du ja auch wirklich, also du wirst ja Geld verdient haben, also drei Dutzend Autos, die wirst du ja alle mit Profit dann verkaufen. Ja. Und dann, also wo ist das Geld? Aber ich sage, muss ich abgeben, grösstenteils. Müssen sie abgeben. Ja. Krass. Und dann haben sie auch einen neuen Namen angenommen, und dann Tietze oder? Stefan, ja. Stefan Tietze statt Slogshire.
Slog, ja.
Okay, danke an Chris für das coole Intro, Chris zwei, der zweite.
Wusstest du, dass Rotkehlchen nur eine Brütezeit von so zwei Monaten haben? Brütenten heißt das Ei vom Legen bis zum Schlüpfen. Zwei Monate ist relativ lang, oder? Also ich weiß gar nicht, ist es lang, ist es kurz, oder? Würdest du nicht auch sagen, dass es sich nicht richtig anfühlt? Es fühlt sich nicht richtig an, nee. Nicht richtig? Naja, aber sind Vögel denn eigentlich mit dem Ei schwanger? Nee. Also das Ei ist ja auch eine Weile im Körper. Das Ei ist schwanger. Das Ei ist schwanger. Okay, aber der Vogel hat ja das Ei erstmal eine Weile dann im Bauch, bevor man es legt. Im Bauch? Oder im Podex. Auch im Podex nicht. Also wo ist das Ei, bevor es gelegt wird? Gebärmutter. Und da muss es aber auch erstmal heranreifen, oder? Also man ist ja schwanger mit einem Ei, erstmal. Das Ei ist ja nicht da und geht sofort raus. Das muss ja heranwachsen, oder nicht? Ganz ehrlich, ich verstehe Eier nicht. Nee, ich auch nicht. Ich finde, ganz ehrlich, und vielleicht bin ich vorher genommen, weil I'm playing for the same team, aber Säugetiere sind schon die sinnvollste Tierart, sorry, sorry, muss ich widersprechen, muss ich widersprechen, also ich habe auch noch offene Fragen bei Ei, wie kommt Luft rein zum Beispiel, also warum erstickt das Küken nicht? Weil die mit einem Ei piekst, dann machst du oben und unten ein Loch ein. Ach so, okay, und dann deswegen der Schnabel, okay, verstehe, hast du einmal, machen die beide Fenster auf, einmal schönen Stoss lüften, okay, ja, nee, das ergibt total Sinn. Aber es ist tatsächlich das Problem, also Säugetier, glaube ich, ist geil bei Rehen oder so, wo das Reh rausploppt und instant wegläuft. Das kann laufen, das kann rechnen, das kann schreiben, das hat irgendwie die fünfte Klasse. Das kann dichten. Das kann dichten, das Reh kann alles. Und wie es bei Gott, wie es dichten kann. Ach, ein absoluter herrlicher Traum. Die Balladen, die Limmerings, ein Gaumenschmaus, ein Genuss. Der Mensch hingegen kann gar nichts. Bis so? Keine Zähne. Wie lange kann ein Mensch nichts? Wirklich bis, keine Ahnung, zwölf, dreizehn oder so. Ich meine... Manche sagen bis zum Ende. Aber manchmal denke ich mir so, das Baby ist zu früh geboren, das ist ja evolutionärer Fakt und so, aber wo ich mir denke, kann man ein bisschen, also manchmal hat man das Gefühl, so kann ich es noch zurückgeben, weil... Was du gerade so weggenuschelt hast als evolutionären Fakt, das Baby ist zu früh geboren. Ja, weil der Kopf zu früh zu groß ist und wenn man später gebären würde, könnte er nicht mehr durch die Anatomie der Frau hindurchflutschen. Warum ist der Kopf so groß, wenn es so dumm ist? Weil das Gehirn ja relativ gross ist als angelegter Mittel von Lesbem. Ja, aber erstmal kann es ja nicht. Aber warum keine fucking Zähne? Also warum müssen die Zähne ausserhalb des Körpers der Mutter heranwachsen? Was soll das? Bullshit. Warum wird es nicht mit Zähnen geboren? Du willst ja kein Zahnwesen in dir drin haben. Doch, klar will ich ein Zahnwesen in mir drin haben, das da schön an der Geburtsnudel nuckelt oder was. Beisst, rumkaut. Ja gut, aber ich meine, lieber als das dann irgendwie dann die Zähne erst ran müssen oder so. Kann nix, wenn es rauskommt. Absolute Katastrophe. Ich finde tatsächlich von den Geburtsmöglichkeiten Säugetier Mensch wirklich mit Abstand das Schlimmste. Känguru macht es besser, Vogel macht es besser, Laich macht es besser. Diese Schildkröten, die einfach sagen, hier komm, zack, hier hast du deinen Strand, schau wie du selber weiterkommst und dann müssen die einmal den Strand entlang, was geil ist, Spaß macht.
Alle Tiere mit so krassen Entwicklungsstufen,
so Pokémon-esken Entwicklungsstufen, wie zum Beispiel Kaulquappe.
Ja.
Oder, sagen wir mal, ähm ...
So Raupe, Schmetterling.
Ja, ja, Raupe.
Wirklich?
Wirklich, es fühlt sich ... sagen wir mal so Raupe, Schmetterling, Bullshit.
Wirklich, es fühlt sich an wie Die alle jetzt einfach
komplett in Müll oder was?
Drag and drop, Papierkopf.
Alle Mülleimer. Möchten sie den Mülleimer
entleeren? Das ist doch
kompletter Nonsens.
Bullshit.
Also wieso denn Raupe? Warum nicht direkt Schmetterling? Ich war in einem Schmetterlingshaus tatsächlich vor kurzem. Du kriegst nicht genug von Schmetterlingshäusern. Ich krieg einfach nicht genug, ich will da rein und die sind ja, die flattern dann auch rum und legen sich hin. Und dann dachte ich mir so, ja, okay, was machen Sie noch für spannende Sachen? Na, die sind schon herrlich anzusehen, herrlich anzusehen. Und dann sieht einen ... Von weitem weg. Ich finde, ganz ehrlich,
Schwindelingshäuser ist eine fucking Geisterbahn,
ist ein Höllenhaus. Ja, das stimmt.
Du musst rein, du musst rein. Es ist warm,
es ist schön, du wirst angefasst. Ich weiß, ich bin auch
ein großer Fan von so Treibhaus-Tropenscheiss.
Ja. Aber
die sind doch von Nahem
sauwiderlich. Und ich wurde mal
in einem von meinen Schwindeln gebissen.
Das ist sehr, sehr widerlich. Wie gebissen, von den Beisswerkzeugen oder von den Flügeln so gekniffen?
Beisswerkzeuge gebissen.
Okay, weil und dann sind da natürlich auch so Leute, die da arbeiten und so und ich habe natürlich immer viel Fragen.
Okay, was passiert denn noch für spannende Sachen? Da arbeiten Leute und die Schmetterlinge fliegen da rum.
Ja, und es ist ein bisschen wärmer als draußen. Es ist ein bisschen wärmer als draußen. Und dann haben die natürlich dann so Flecken auf ihren Flügeln, die so aussehen wie Augen. Und dann habe ich gefragt, aha, sollen das Augen sein? So, und der Mitarbeiter, natürlich so schlau wie du, Evolution sagt dann, naja, beim evolutionären Entwicklung kann man ja schlecht davon reden, dass es Augen sein sollen. Die Evolution hat ja kein Ziel sozusagen.
Love him.
Weißt du was, du fütterst Mandarinenstückchen an Schmetterlinge und okay, du bist schlau, du bist cool, meine Frage ist dumm.
Du mit deinem Evolutionsstress, du laberst so ein Unser in dein Evolutionskram, Emma.
Ja, es ist wirklich.
Dass dir da mal jemand die Leviten liest, was auch immer das ist.
Keine Ahnung.
Wurden dir da die Leviten gelesen?
Nee, wurden mir tatsächlich leider nicht gelesen.
Ich hätte mir gerne ein paar Leviten angehört, weil ich habe kaum Leviten.
Ich habe fast nichts von Leviten.
Ich wünschte, dass dir mal so richtig die Leviten gelesen wäre.
Ich wünschte mir auch, da stehen viele coole Sachen drin.
Da wurden die Leviten gelesen. Und da habe ich mich auch gefragt stehen viele coole Sachen drin. Da wurden die Leviten gelesen.
Und da habe ich mich auch gefragt, ja, aber wie ist es denn, hier hängen dann auch Kokons rum.
Kannst du auch für diese Mitarbeiter zu belästigen.
Du hast dann mit dem Hergelauf das Fragen gestellt.
Da hängen dann so eine Art wie Baumstämme von der Decke und da hängen dann Kokons.
Und dann frage ich mich ja, warum legen die alle ihre Kokons denn da hin?
Also warum legen die die alle an denselben Ort? Und dann meinte er, nee, nee, nee, die kaufen wir ein und hängen dann da hin. Nein, sag doch mal zu, wir hängen die einfach auf, wir kaufen die und hängen die da hin. Das Leben ist kein Kreis, das Leben beginnt in einem fucking Amazon-Store, wo du dir einfach diese Kokons kaufst, so 12 Centes Stück. Das ist die ganzemetterlinge hier, es sind kleine Roboter. So ein abgeklärter Typ. Ja, weil die Korkons hingen alle mit so Pinnadeln. Da dachte ich, das ist jetzt aber evolutionär gesehen verrückt, dass die Schmetterlinge sich diese Pinnadeln organisieren oder wie, weil die sich da soll ich das da hinkleben, soll ich Klebstoff produzieren? Nein, stellt sich raus, die kaufen die Concours, hängen da hin, dann schlüpfen die und dann ...
Die kaufen die Concours.
Das heißt, da gibt es gar keine natürliche Fortpatsung.
Wo kauft man die Concours?
Das habe ich tatsächlich nicht gefragt.
Und kaufst du sozusagen den Schmetterling im Concours oder steht da ehrlich drauf, was es wird?
Was ist so ein Überraschungsei?
Ich glaube, es ist ein Überraschungsei.
Du kriegst eine Wundertüte, du kriegst eine gemischte bunte Tüte und weißt nicht, ob dann am Ende ein Zitronenfall da oder ein Klapskalier da drin ist. Weißt du auch nicht. Ja, und dann musst du halt ein bisschen Glück haben. Ich behaupte ja, dass der Hund in meinem Leben die anderen Hunde seiner Rasse, Cockerspaniel, erkennt. Ja, und die anderen Hunde nicht. Doch, doch, doch, doch. Aber ich glaube, er fühlt sich seines Wesens nach, anderen Kockerspanien näher. Ja. Vom Wesen her. Und auch von der Grösse und Augenhöhe und Geruch wahrscheinlich. Erst mal eine Frage. Weiss eine Raupe, die ein Zitronenfalter wird, wenn sie einen Zitronenfalter sieht, das bin ich. Das bin ich mal. Oder ist die Raupe komplett planlos?
Ich glaube, die Raupe, das ist halt so wie bei uns Menschen auch so.
Klar, du siehst vielleicht einen Architekten und denkst dir, Architektur wäre cool, aber du weisst es nicht, ob du das am Ende wirst.
Und dann gehst du zu einer Berufsberatung und die sagen dir dann Elfenbeinschnitzer und so.
Und du denkst dir, kann ich mich jetzt nicht so hundertprozentig mit identifizieren, kann man Elfenbein überhaupt schnitzen, wie hart ist Elfenbein, wo zur Hölle kriege ich Elfenbein her. Das sind dann so die Fragen, die man sich stellt. Und dann am Ende des Tages bist du dann irgendein Mitarbeiter im Schmetterlingshaus und hast damit auch nicht gerechnet. Ich glaube, so ist es bei den Raupen auch. Die haben Wünsche und Träume und können sich denken, ich bin eigentlich ganz gut in meinen Händen,
ich könnte mir vorstellen, in so einem Eisladen zu arbeiten, wo man dann so die Eiskugeln
und so, aber am Ende bist du was komplett
anderes, am Ende bist du Podcaster und denkst dir,
okay, wow. Raupencast.
Raupencast, so, das hätt's auch nicht so.
Der Cast aus dem Kokon, Kokoncast.
Rotkehlchen, Funfact, essen
Raupen gern.
Vom Boden
weg. Vom Bogen
picken sie die ab.
Vielen Dank. Fun Fact, essen Raupen gern vom Boden weg. Vom Bogen picken sie die ab. Und dann habe ich Kakao gesehen. In derselben Etablismeng gab es sowohl Schmetterlinge als auch Kakao, also wie ich die Kakaopflanze. Aber war das, würdest du sagen, immer noch ein gutes Verhältnis, also ein Kakao-Schmetterling-Verhältnis? Weil immer muss man das Kakao-Haus nennen. Naja. Verstehst du, was ich meine. Naja. Da verstehst du, was ich meine. Ich verstehe total, was du meinst. Das Kakao-Verhältnis ist nicht immer ideal, aber es ist ja purer Kakao. Das ist ja dann schon kräftig. Das ist ja 100 Prozent Kakao. Schokolade hat ja irgendwie 50 Prozent Kakao. Warst du beim Schokoladenmuseum in Köln? Ja, da haben wir doch sogar gedreht, Stefan. Nee, nee, ich meine nicht... Sarotti-Museum. Ob du das mal besucht hast, sondern ob du das mal verinnerlicht hast. Ob du weisst, wie Kakao funktioniert. Okay, aber das muss in der Frage ja irgendwie ... Hast du in der Frage ja irgendwie ... Oder auch gesehen? Hä? Weisst du, wie Schokolade entsteht? Nein. Ich war im Schokolade-Museum, ich habe mich unter den Schokobrunnen gelegt. Und bis ich war und dann musste ich, weil ich auch im Koma … Wir mussten dich da rausschneiden. Auch im Koma hatte ich noch den Mund offen und am Ende war ich komplett mit Schokolade überzogen. Dadurch wurde dann dieser, dann hast du das aber so, der Mechanismus sich mehr abgeflossen, es wurde nicht mehr hochgepumpt, dadurch ist der ausgegangen und die wurde hart, die Schokolade, weil die nicht mehr gewärmt wurde. Und dann musste dich da die Feuerwehr aus dem Schokoladenboden
schneiden. Ich war dabei.
Ja, du standest neben der Flex und hast
die Flexspäne gegessen.
Du hattest schön auf den Mund auf, die Flexspäne hast du
gegessen. Und dann musste ich da rausgestanden werden, war
ich nicht stolz drauf, aber zum Glück habe ich das meiste nicht
mitbekommen, weil ich bewusstlos war.
Aber nein, ich weiss nicht genau, wie Schokolade
hergestellt wird.
Kakaopulver und Zucker und Butter, Kakaobutter, sagt man nicht Kakaobutter? Ja. Und Milch. Okay, das ist doch wunderbar, das ist doch gut. Aber dann waren da so die Kakaopflanzen mit diesen Kakaofrüchten. Ja, lecker. Und da stand da, bitte nicht klauen, das ist durchaus wertvoll. Das sollte man so nicht machen. Und weil so eine komplette Kakao ist tatsächlich nicht wenig wert. Weil da kriegst du ja richtig viel raus. Und dann dachte ich mir so, das ist auch das Dümmste, was man da hinschreiben kann. Bitte nicht klauen, sehr wertvoll. Und ich dachte, ich bin ein rechtsmässiger, gesetzestreuer Mensch. Aber selbst ich dachte mir, na gut, in der Tasche, hier, Ablenkung, ich drehe da eine Schildkröte, ich lege alle Schildkröten auf den Rücken, so, und bis die Mitarbeiter alle wieder auf die richtige Seite gedreht haben, bin ich raus mit fünf Kakaobohnen, ist doch kein Problem. Aber Moment mal kurz, ich kann mein Geld in Kakaobohnen anlegen? Ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, doch. Moment mal kurz, ich kann Schildkröten drehen? Ja, ja, ja, der Horizont wird erweitert heute, aber ich denke mir vor allem, Schokolade ist doch ultra billig, so, du hast doch bei Kamelle, bei Karneval haben die doch diese Schokoladenlutscher oder so, hauen die doch da raus, wie nix schmeißen die einfach nicht gegen, aber da ist ja auch Kakao. Aber weisst du, wie viel aus einer Kakaobohne entstehen kann? Nein. Du weisst, ich war bewusstlos im Schokoladenmuseum. Ich habe diese Zahlen nicht verinnerlicht. Ich weiss, wir müssen nicht da rausschneiden. Ja, ich hatte harte Schokolade in der Lunge. Meine Lunge war komplett gefüllt. Die haben die Schokolade aus meiner Lunge gezogen und es war ein perfekter Abdruck meiner Lunge. Und da waren noch ein paar Legosteine mit drin. Weisst du, wie unangenehm das war im Krankenhaus? Lustigerweise macht dieses Schild bei dieser Kakaobohne bei mir, aber das Gegenteil. Ich denke, dann halte ich mit dem Vater von dem blonden Jungen bei Game of Thrones. Wie heißt der denn noch? Tywin. Ja, Lannister. Wie heißt der Sohn? Baron, Baron Trump. Baron. Nee, wen meinst du jetzt, Tyrion Lannister ist der Sohn von Tywin. Der blonde, der blonde. Der Peter Dinklage, das ist Tyrion Lannister. Nein, nein, nein, nein, der kleine blonde Junge, den alle hassen. Ach, Joffrey. Joffrey, so, dessen Vater. Ja, Tywin. Da, wo wir am Anfang begonnen haben. Der sagt, wenn du sagen musst, I am the King,
bist du nicht der King.
Jetzt mal frei übersetzt.
Frei und nur zur Hälfte übersetzt.
Wenn dich jemand fragt, was machst du beruflich?
Was sagst du dann?
Ich bin jetzt hier ganz nah an dem Paradoxon.
I'm a monarch,
I'd say.
Prince King. Stimmt, das ist eine gute Frage. Ich meine, wenn du als Kakaobohne sagen musst, recht wertvoll, nicht klauen, die ist schon sehr wertvoll, mach das Schild mit mir, ja, wie wertvoll kann es sein. Wenn die so wertvoll wäre, dann würde die ja nicht hier sein, in einem Schmetterlingshaus. Vor allem, ich finde, nicht klauen ist eine generelle Regel, die man nicht nochmal explizit dazuschreiben muss. Weil es ist auch so, bitte nicht Kakao klauen, ja okay, und alles andere kann ich klauen oder was. Den Vokal kann ich mitnehmen oder was einfach. So, das finde ich da ein bisschen schwierig. Und ich kriege so Sprichwort-Vibes, die Kakaobohnen im Schmetterlingshaus. Weißt du, was ich meine? Das ist so Elefanten-Portellan-Laden-mäßig. Na, Moment mal, das müsste eigentlich etwas sein, was sehr wertvoll ist in einer Umgebung, wo eigentlich alles wertlos ist.
Nee, das sehe ich nicht so.
Nee?
In einer Umgebung, die nichts mit dem Ursprungsgegenstand zu tun hat.
Also wie zum Beispiel ...
Ach so.
Ein sehr talentiertes Kind in der Schulklasse von dummen Kindern, sagt man.
Du bist die Kakaobohne im Schmetterlingshaus.
Du stichst raus als was besonders Gutes.
Oder was meinst du, oder wo bist du gerade? Aber ich verstehe gar nicht, warum Schmetterlinge so abwertest. Die sind doch mega cool. Es ist etwas Cooles, Talentiertes, Teures, Wertvolles, Krasses in einem Umfeld, was schon auch seine Daseinsberechtigung hat. Aber die zwei Dinge hängen nicht unbedingt miteinander zusammen. Also du meinst, die die Kehrseite von Blindes Huhn findet auch mal ein Korn.
Zum Beispiel, ja.
Sondern du bist unter den Besten nochmal der Beste.
Du bist was Cooles in einem, wie zum Beispiel wenn jetzt, ja genau.
Okay.
Warte, Jamal Musiala, der Fussballspieler der deutschen Nationalmannschaft,
guckt sich bei, wie heißt dieser krasse Basketballverein in München auch? Stefan, weiss ich nicht, wie heißen die, Telekom-Eisbären? Ich habe keine Ahnung, der Basketballverein von München, wer bin ich denn? Du kommst oder her, du kommst oder her, oder NBA, Mavericks, Jamal Musiala, deutscher Fussballnationalspieler, guckt sich ein Spiel an von dem Dallas Mavericks. Okay. Er ist die Kakaobohne im Schmetterlingshaus. Nein, das ergibt keinen Sinn. Nee, du müsstest sowas sagen wie, wenn du sagst, ich sag, oh, Kobe Bryant ist der beste Spieler aller Zeiten, dann sag ich, naja, ist auch nur eine Kakaobohne im Schmetterlingshaus. Sprich, er ist zwar sehr gut, aber sein Umfeld ist auch sehr gut. Der Abstand ist nicht so gross, wie du sagst. Ich finde das wichtig, Thomas Hüller guckt Basketball, er ist die Kakaubone im Schmetterlingshaus. Aber der spielt doch nicht mit. Die Kakaubone und Schmetterling haben auch nichts miteinander gemeint. Aber du hast doch gesagt, die Aussage des Sprichworts ist, dass beides gut ist. Ja, für sich in verschiedenen Kategorien, genau. Ja, aber was sagt denn dieses Sprichwort aus? Aber Kobe Bryant ist ja Basketballer. Aber was ist denn die Aussage des Sprichwortes? Keins. Wie keins? Nee, ich finde, es würde Sinn ergeben, angenommen, du überhörst jemanden aus meiner Perspektive. Du sagst, Kobe Bryant, Jahrhundertspieler, der würde ganz alleine gegen fünf gewinnen, der ist super stark und dann könnte ich das Sprichwort nutzen, der ist auch nur eine Kakaobohne im Schmetterlingshaus. Aber wo ist er denn dann? Im Schmetterlingshaus, die Schmetterlings sind gut, aber Kakaobonen sind auch gut. Das ist aber mein erstes, nein, nein, nein, aber gut, in welcher Kategorie? Generell gut. Jetzt im Kontext Basketballspieler. Aber Kobe Bryant ist einer der besten Basketballer gewesen. Ja, aber er ist nicht so viel besser als die, mit denen er spielt. Aber er wäre ja sogar die krasseste Kakaobohne in einem Kakaobohnenhaus. Ja, aber er ist auch nur eine Kakaobohne und ein Schmetterling. Er ist nicht so viel besser. Nein, Schmetterlinge sind ja was ganz anderes und in ihrer Kategorie auch super. Aber Thomas Müller zum Beispiel bei einem Basketballspiel
ist eine Kakaobone
im Schminderlingshaus. Er ist gut.
Aber er schaut doch nur zu.
Er macht doch nichts. Nee, aber er ist ein guter
Fussballer
vor dem Kontext eines anderen tollen
weisen nicht talentierten Menschen.
Okay.
Also sagen wir jetzt mal, Rihanna
spielt in einem Film. Nur um es so gesagt zu haben. Kannst du aufhören, dunkelhäutige Menschen zu nehmen. POCs, wir nennen die ganze Zeit aus Versehen POCs und nennen die ... Das war gar kein ... Nee, ich weiß, ich will nur sagen, dass es mir immer aufgefallen ist, ich dachte ... Lady Gaga spielt ja auch mit, zum Beispiel bei Joker. Jetzt ist Lady Gaga aber primär als Musikerin bekannt. So, jetzt sagst du, also jetzt sag ich, ey, Lady Gaga ist eine Kakaobohne im Schmetterlingshaus. Wo ist sie gerade? Sie spielt mit in Joker, mit anderen Schauspielern, aber sie ist quasi was anderes Gutes, aber sie ist unter anderen Guten und alles ist gut. Ja, das ist doch für mich das Sprichwort.
Okay.
Das ist ein sehr, sehr spezielles Sprichwort, was nur in manchen Situationen auch ein annähernd.
Aber jetzt kommt meine Left-Fielder-Frage.
Was, wenn Schmetterlinge sich ernähren von Kakaobohnen?
Okay.
Ne, aber tun sie das oder warum hängen die Kakaobohnen da um?
Nee, ich glaube nicht. Einfach wegen der Wärme. Die kommen da nicht rein, glaube ich, in die Kakaobohne. Die hat ja eine relativ harte Schale. Glaube ich, die ist relativ safe. Da haben wir es. Wie Leliga. Wie Liga, ja, okay. Perfekt. Ja, also, nutzt gerne dieses Sprichwort in den zwei Situationen eures Lebens, wo das vielleicht mal vorkommt. Aber ich finde es,
was wäre denn ein anderes gutes Sprichwort für die
Kobe-Bryan-Situation? Also,
der ist zwar
gut, aber er ist jetzt
nicht so viel besser als die anderen. Also
ein Anti-Überhöhungssprichwort
zu sagen,
der ist auch nicht so viel besser als
die anderen. Der ist, also Dann ist ja die Frage, warum man ihn überhaupt mit einem Sprichwort würdigt. Also, verstehst du, was ich meine? Ein Sprichwort ist ja gemeinhin, um eine besondere Situation zu beschreiben. Gut, aber zum Beispiel, du bist großer Fan von Timothée Chalamet. Lieb ich. Und du schaust Dune an und sagst, ah, Timothée Chalamet, so gut, so toll, so ein toller Schauspiel. Ja. Ich denke mir ja, ich mag auch Timothy Chalamet, ich möchte aber den Rest des Casts auch würdigen und würde sagen, ey, Timothy Chalamet ist auch nur das weisse Gummibärchen in der Gummibärchenpackung. Er ist der beste, klar, aber der Unterschied zu den anderen ist nicht so gross. Das weisse Gummibärchen ist mit Abstand das schlechteste Gummibärchen. Das ist das Beste, das ist Erdbeere. Das weisse? Nee, das grüne ist Erdbeere. Das weisse ist, glaube ich, Grapefruit. Das grüne ist Erdbeere? Das grüne ist Erdbeere, ja. Bist du komplett bescheuert? Ja, das ist jetzt wirklich, das ist eine 1998er-Diskussion. Aber verstehst du, was ich meine? Ja, ja, ich glaube nur, der Fakt, dass du jemanden mit einem Sprichwort würdigst, steht deinem konkreten Vorstoß entgegen, dass du das Besondere kleiner machen willst. Genau, ich will gegen die Überhöhung argumentieren. Ich will sagen, ey, Timothy Chalamet ist auch nur das Zitronen nimmt zwei, von der Packung nimmt zwei. In den zwei Sorten gibt. Zitronen Nimmzweiss und Orangen
Nimmzweiss. Das Problem ist, du musst ja einen
Konsens haben, was besser ist. Und du musst
wissen, was dein Gegenüber mag.
Ja, man bräuchte eigentlich etwas,
wo alle Leute denken, es sei
das Beste, aber es
ist nur deswegen gut, weil es in
einem Kontext von einem Ensemble
von auch guten Sachen ist.
Wie bei Celebrations des Snickers. Okay, ey, Timothy Chalamet ist auch nur des Snickers in Celebrations. Boah, da würde ich sagen, ja, weil der Rest ist Trash. Ja, es waren jetzt auch nicht Zendaya ist das Dove. Moment, wir sind uns einig, in Dune 2 nicht jeder Schauspieler war gut.
Wäre, war nicht gut.
Da gab's Durchhänger.
Wer war Mars? Wer war das Mars?
War das Bounty, meinst du?
Ja.
Nee, wen fandst du am schlechtesten?
Nee, ja, ach ja gut, ich fand jetzt Gaskart nicht so überragend.
Sorry.
Aber ich hab auch keine Antwort.
Nee, ich mein nur, aber so, und jetzt bräuchte man nämlich das, aber stopp, jetzt bräuch bräuchte man nämlich das... Was ist die schlechteste schauspielerische Leistung? Florentin, ich will jetzt, Florentin will in Klammern Schauspieler. Was war für dich die schlechteste schauspielerische Performance eines Stars im letzten Jahr? Ich habe keinen Film gesehen im letzten Jahr. So eine richtig trashige ... Das ist eine unangenehme Frage. Ich kann das auch nicht so gut bewerten, ehrlich gesagt. Ich nehme mir da kein Urteil raus. Aber ich fand jetzt zum Beispiel ... Jack Black in Jumanji nicht so stark. Also, muss ich jetzt auch ... Also, sorry, ich bin einer Fan. Ich finde, der hat wirklich, also der hat auch Bounty-Momente und Dove-Momente. Aber jetzt bräuchten wir ein Sprichwort für, er ist der Schlechteste im Ensemble, aber er ist trotzdem noch sehr gut. Er ist der Blinde unter den Königen oder so? Ja, nee. Nee, der Blinde ist unter den Königen der, nee. Nee. Der König unter den Blinden? Der Einäugige ist der König unter den Blinden. Ja. Aber das sagt ja, die alle sind so grottenschlecht, dass selbst etwas besser dich zum König macht. Ich wollte mal ein Sprichwort, fällt mir gerade ein, machen, was ähnlich ist.
Also irgendwie, ich habe es noch nicht ganz geknackt.
Aber das ist ein Blinder in einem dunklen Raum.
Okay.
Also sozusagen.
Seine Schwäche macht gar keinen Unterschied.
Oder sogar für zum Gegenteil.
Ein Blinder im dunklen Raum kommt aber besser klar als ein Sehender im dunklen Raum. So ein bisschen Fish in the water. Der Fisch im Wasser, der Blinde ist im Dunkeln ein Fisch im Wasser. Wohingegen der Elch? Nee, aber das stimmt auch nicht. Ein Blinder im Dunkeln ist nicht ein Fisch im Wasser. Der Fisch kann nur im Wasser überleben. Der Blinde kann, für den macht es keinen Unterschied, weißt du, was ich meine? Amphibien. Die Schwalbe im Windkanal, so ein bisschen so. Die brilliert da, aber die Schwalbe ist... Kann aber auch ohne Wind. Boah, ich muss echt sagen, irgendwie, Timothy Schellemey war echt so die Schwalbe im Windkanal. Also, ne? Man weiss es auch. Okay. Benutzt mal mehr Sprichwörter, um es so ein bisschen aufzulockern. Frage, Timothy Chalamet war bei der Berlinale und hat einen ... Hast du ihn gesehen? Hast du ihm Shrimps angeboten? Ich hab ihn bei TikTok gesehen, ja. Und er hatte einen pinken Hoodie an und so eine pinke Jogginghose. Das war sein Red Carpet Outfit. Da gab es, habe ich mitbekommen, gemischte Gefühle zu. Oh. Weil rote Teppich, du bist irgendwie genau farbliche Unterschiede. Und natürlich, wie schick muss man sich machen, wenn man mit seinem Film Premiere hat. Sehr gute Frage. Das ist Respekt aus einem A-Festival. Ja, ja, sehr gute Frage, die mich sehr selbst auch beeinflusst. Mode ist bei mir immer natürlich ein Thema gewesen, das man sich immer überlegt, aber für mich sticht Mode natürlich auch im natürlichen Konventionsbruch raus. Genau. Deswegen kann natürlich der, der sich genauso anzieht wie alle anderen,
viel mehr habe ich nicht.
Da kommt immer viel.
Ich sage mal so,
die Snickers sind schon weg aus der Celebration.
Ah, okay.
Den Rest können wir wegwerfen.
Jetzt kommt nur noch Bounty.
Und deswegen ist natürlich der Skandal, das Augenmerk,
das Herausreissen aus der Sehgewohnheit nicht der eigentliche modische Akt, weiß ich nicht. Ihr modischer Akt war es, die Frage ist nur, war es ein guter oder ein schlechter Akt? Du willst ja auch immer was dabei haben, ne? Und so ein Hoodie, du hast ja immer eine schöne Taschentuch. Was hast du da in deinem Hoodie drin? Taschentuch. Ja, nicht cool. Taschentuch im Hoodie, ja. Aber geht's dir jetzt wieder gut? Ach ja, ich weiss nicht. Ich habe wirklich die kompletten Schweizer Alpen abgetragen an Ricola. Ich habe wirklich so viel Ricola in mir. Die werden da rausgehauen. Ich glaube, ich kann wirklich bald eine Schweizer Staatsbürgerschaft beantragen, weil ich zu 80 Prozent aus dem Köln- Ja, vielleicht besser so. Letztens auch Tobleroneone wieder geholt. Ja. Das war wirklich, da war ich, vor allem das war eine merkwürdige Situation, weil wenn ich einkaufen gehe, belohne ich mich auch gerne. Und dann waren die Kassen so und es gab eine Kasse, wo relativ wenig los war, da habe ich mich dahingestellt. Und dann dachte ich, oh. Self-Track-Out? Nein, nein, nein, nein, gibt es nicht. Da dachte ich mir, oh, ich habe noch gar nicht meine Belohnung für heute. Ich will einen kleinen Snack. Normalerweise ist es ein Milka-Tender, ein Yes-Shorty, je nachdem. Sunrise. Sunrise gibt es leider da, wo ich oft einkaufe, nicht. Ja, das Privileg hast nur du. Also schaue ich, oh, ich bin an der Alkoholkasse, wo da irgendwie Underberg und kleiner Wodka und so.
So, da habe ich eine Frage.
Warum sind Kassen unterschiedlich ausgestattet?
Ganz merkwürdig, ganz merke dich.
Es gibt die Batterienkasse.
Genau.
Es gibt die Zigarettenkasse.
Nee, Zigaretten sind mal nicht überall.
Genau, Zigaretten sind meistens überall.
Dann gibt es die Alkoholfasche und die Goldkasse.
Und die Kaugummi und die Snackkasse.
Genau.
So, und du, ich bin oft zu Gedanken verloren in meinem Podcast oder was auch immer, dass ich zu spät merke, oh fuck, ich bin an der Spirituosenkasse, für mich gibt es hier keinen Snack. Also, panischer Blick und ich sehe, ganz unten unter den Spirituosen gibt es eine Reihe Toblerone. What the fuck, okay, dann kann ich jetzt eine komplette Toblerone, Tafel, wie sagt man da, Stange, kann ich die mitnehmen? Muss ja, muss ja, ich kann ja, ich schaue nach links und bei mir die Reihe ist voll, ich will nicht durch die Genitalien der anderen Wartenden durchgreifen, um an mein geliebtes Tender zu kommen, geht nicht. Also stecke ich fest, also haue ich mir Toblerone rein in den Wagen.
So, dann an der Kasse, alles schon aufgelegt, die Person vor mir zahlt, mit Karte bitte, holt aber keine Karte raus, mit Karte bitte, zieht den Ärmel zurück, Apple Watch, scannt Apple Watch an dem Gerät, das Gerät geht aus. Strom im Supermarkt geht aus. Das Kartenlesegerät geht aus. Komplett schwarz. Nach einer Weile geht es wieder an. Komplett so krisseln. Nur krisseln. Ist hinüber. Geht nicht mehr. Die Kassiererin auch, ich weiß gar nicht, was man machen kann, soll ich nochmal neu starten? Egon, kommst du mal irgendwie hin und her, alle Katastrophe, letzten Endes zehn Minuten lang gewartet, geht nichts voran,
einfach komplett der Blackout, zerstört EMP,
alle Schaltkreise verschmort.
Wahnsinn, ja.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es so eine Hacker-Apple-Watch war,
weil das war so eine nette, mittelalte Dame,
die wahrscheinlich sich gedacht hat,
ich habe zu Weihnachten meine Apple-Watch bekommen von meinen Kindern
und so, jetzt probiere ich das mal aus.
Und dann auch so, wahrscheinlich hat sie so etwas gesagt wie, und die kann ich einfach an die Kasse halten, geht das dann nicht kaputt und alle so Mama, was denn Quatt und sie zum ersten Mal so mega nervös, okay, ich versuch's mal mit Tartewitze, hältst dran, einfach in die Luft. Komplett aus. Aber was ich super spannend finde, dass ich jetzt zum ersten Mal etwas beobachte,
dass die Entwicklung weiter ist,
technische Entwicklung weiter ist als das Vokabular. Man sagt, das mag ich ja die ganze Zeit, bezahle ich mit Handy.
Sehr gut.
Und es ist, genau, das ist meine Gegenwart-Ebebachtung. Nina, willst du, den Punkt hast du.
Es ist, du sagst mit Karte bitte, und alle holen ihre Apple-Watches oder iPhones her iPhones hervor oder Android Geräte, aber es ist so ein bisschen wie wie die Diskette als Speichersymbol, irgendwann weiss überhaupt niemand, was Karten sind.
Ja genau, oder sowas wie, keine Ahnung, es gibt dieses, mach mal keine fiese Matenten, dieses Sprichwort, niemand weiss, woher kommt das und dann kommt es irgendwie, hast du noch nie gehört?
Vielleicht ist das ein Ruhrgebiet-Ding, aber es kommt aus dem Ersten Weltkrieg mit den Franzosen, meine ich, mit Vison, Matent oder so. Also haben die zu den Frauen gesagt. Ich verstehe immer weniger. Nein, aber Besuche mein Zelt, meine ich so, fiese Matenten. Und das wurde dann daraus irgendwann so ein Wort, und irgendwann verliert aber die Herkunft. Ja, genau. Es ist ein eigenes Wort, obwohl es eigentlich eine Bedeutung hat. Und mit Karte bitte hat das gleiche. Weiß nicht, noch für Beispiele. Das stimmt, weil ich glaube nicht, dass man irgendwann sagen würde, Digitalzahlen bitte oder Kontaktlos zahlen bitte. Kontaktlos zahlen bitte, fuck you, Jesus. Nein, es bleibt bei Karte. Kriegst du einen Punkt? Du kriegst den Punkt auf jeden Fall. Nena, krie kriegst den Punkt mit Karte auf jeden Fall dabei.
Und es war eine super blöde Situation, weil sie hatte ihren Einkauf schon eingepackt, mein Einkauf lag auf dem Band und es war dann so, ja es geht nicht, ich kann nicht zahlen und dann musste sie den kompletten Einkauf nochmal auf ein anderes Band legen, ich musste alles wieder abräumen und dann habe ich mich an einer anderen Kasse angestellt, wo ich wieder Zugang zu Tender hatte. Aber das Toblerone blieb weiterhin frei. So, und jetzt war ich natürlich in einer misslichen Lage.
Ich denke, okay, das Schicksal hat mir jetzt relativ deutlich gezeigt. Du warst Kakaobohnen im Spetterlingshaus. In gewisser Weise, ja. Nee, also genau. Ja, ich war die Kirsche in der Zweipackung, in der Lachgummipackung. Sahnetorte, ja. Und dann habe ich tatsächlich noch drei Tendern mitgenommen und hatte dann auf der Heimfahrt hatte ich Toblerone und habe aber gelernt, habe mich daran erinnert, wie man Toblerone richtig isst, nämlich man bricht die Rippen nach innen in die Richtung des Riegels ab, nicht nach außen, was der Deutsche dummerweise tun würde, denkt sich, reiss das ab, aber du musst es, was auch nicht immer leicht ist, weil dadurch schmilzt es schon so ein bisschen an und wie macht man das mit der Alufolie, also da habe ich gemerkt, im Herzen bin ich doch noch kein Schweizer, obwohl ich wirklich in meinen Adern Ricola fließt. Und boykottierst du jetzt amerikanische Produkte? Nein. Ich habe überlegt, das ist so spannend, weil, na gut, doch Apple muss man dann. Also angenommen, man will jetzt amerikanische Produkte oder was jetzt auch gerade so im Internet rumgeht, irgendwie so Cloud Storages, dass man da ein bisschen Angst vorhaben kann als Europäer, wenn jetzt irgendwie und alle amerikanischen, alle so typischen Cloud Services wie Dropbox, Google Drive oder iCloud, das ist ja alles amerikanisch. Das heisst, da wird es schwierig. Aber sonst habe ich so gedacht, wenn jetzt Trump mit seinen Zöllen ankommt bei Europa, dachte ich mir so, wo ist man denn von amerikanischen Produkten konfrontiert. So im Everyday-Live-Supermarkt, glaube ich, nehme ich gar nicht so viel. Ich weiß es gar nicht, wenn ich gesagt habe. Technisch und dann so Kram natürlich. So Dr. Pepper oder sowas? Das wird dann auch in Deutschland produziert. Aber das ist ein negativer Einfluss auf dein Leben, wenn du 25 Prozent mehr auf Dr. Pepper zahlen musst. Oh fuck. Tatsächlich, fuck. Ich finde, Dr. Pepper ist, ähm, okay, wie kriege ich das hin? Ich finde, bei Dr. Pepper, was hatten wir jetzt gesagt, als, nee, bei Dr. Pepper finde ich, ist die Leitvariante die Kakaobohne unter den Schmetterlingen. Warte, warte, bei Dr. Pepper, was schon nicht das griffigste Getränke ist, weil ich auch nicht genau weiß, wie du das so stehst, ist die Light-Variante, ah, du findest sie gut. Ich find sie gut, genau. Und ich find den Abstand zwischen Light und Nicht-Light ist bei Dr. Pepper am kleinsten von allen Softdrinks. Weißt du, warum ich gerade Bock habe? Dieser isotonische Drink. Kennst du den noch aus dem Algin? Oh geil, dieses blaue, schlumpfblaue. Oh, ich muss heute noch Marathon reden. Weil dieser Blauton ist so lecker. Er ist lecker, ja. Und dann hast du dieses etwas leicht bittere Limonen getränkt. so. Genau, der hat fast eine natürliche Herbe drin, die gar nicht reinpasst, weil das wahrscheinlich ultra künstlich ist, aber es hatte alles in der Farbe sagt, künstlich, künstlich, künstlich. Genau, aber es hatte so eine Bitterkeit, wo man denkt, oh, diese Bitterkeit hast du bei Zitrone nur bei wirklichem Tarteau-Citron, so richtig schön vom Bäcker. Suggeriert irgendwie eine Natürlichkeit, die gar nicht da ist. Genau, weil die Idee von Zitrone ist ja, du ballerst so lange Zucker rein, bis du das Bittere nicht mehr schmeckst. Und dann hast du Limonade oder nimm zwei oder was auch immer. Aber da, Dr. Pepper bin ich da tatsächlich dabei, hole ich mir oft auch die Zero-Variante und bin ich dabei. Aber was ich jetzt letztens gesehen habe, und da bin ich jetzt wieder eher im Norwegischen unterwegs, Denn ich habe ja immer Ausschau nach so unorthodoxen Riegeln, weil oft werden ja Dinge verriegelt, wo man denkt, müssen die verriegelt werden? Also Dummle zum Beispiel gibt es jetzt als Riegel. Dummle kennen die meisten wahrscheinlich von Ikea als schwedisches Kaubonbon, was man immer zwischen den Zähnen hat, während man ein Billiregal aufbaut. Wenn man flucht, dieses Drecksscheiß Billiregal und man flucht und es kommen immer so ein paar Brocken Dummle mit. Was ist Dummle? Weil man sich beim Ikea irgendwie bei der Süßigkeitenabteilung danach einen schönen Hotdog geholt hat und eine Riesenpackung Dummle. Und Dummle ist so ein bisschen, wäre das Riesenmässig. Also so Karamellkern mit Schokolade drum. Nicht ganz so kräftig, nicht ganz so heftig. Hol euch Gifla. Gifla auch nicht schlecht, ja, auch gut diese Zimtschnecken. Ja. Aber Dummle ist für mich so der Klassiker, gab es auch lange im Spekulatius-Weihnachtsmodus, weil ich zu Weihnachten viel Ecke eingekauft habe. Lecker. Und Dummle gibt es jetzt auch als Riegle. Das heißt, du hast jetzt den Dummle-Riegle und den habe ich noch nicht probiert, weil ich mir denke, wie soll das sein, wenn es heißt Wärters Riesen der Riegel. Wer das Riegel. Das heißt, du hast jetzt den dummle Riegel und den habe ich noch nicht probiert, weil ich mir denke, wie soll das sein, wenn es heißt Wärters Riesen der Riegel, Wärters Riegel funktioniert für mich auch nicht. Aber ich habe immer ein Auge drauf und jetzt habe ich letztens gesehen, weil ich bin ein großer Fan von Smash. Schoko Smash. Und was ist Schoko Smash? Und scheiss, du liebst eine andere Welt, Snacktechnik, das ist so crazy. Weil ich mag ja immer die Kombination aus Herb und Süss, ja, also Schnitzel mit Preiselbeeren oder so, finde ich mal richtig geil. Und ich weiß nicht, warum es die Süßigkeitenindustrie es nicht rafft, das mal endlich in vernünftiges Produkt zu pressen. So, und jetzt gibt es mittlerweile Lichtblicke, denn es gibt sowas wie Chips mit Schokoladenmantel oder so auch Nachos mit Schokoladenmantel, sowas sind der rechte. Ja, diese kleinen Brezel, Snackbrezel, die gibt es mit Vollmilchschokoladen, die sind richtig lecker, richtig lecker. Und da gibt es auch Schoko Smash, und Schoko Smash sind so ein bisschen wie so kleine Tornados. Kennst du so diese Tornados? Du kannst Snacks, die ich nicht kenne, mit Snacks erklären, die ich nicht kenne. Nee, es ist kein Snack. Wir sind jetzt schon in der vierten Iter Iteration. Wir sind jetzt einfach in der Windhosenform. Wie erkläre ich Dummle? Ja, mit Smash. Kennst du Sunrise? Nein. Es ist so ein bisschen wie Tornados mit Sunrise. Relsons und die, aber wenn du Tornados, kennst du was mit Tornados, aber ohne Schaumstoff. Es gibt die Tornados, die so ein bisschen, na so eine Art Herbert Churro sind.
Das ist so ein bisschen, also das ist wie ein Tornado,
aber die sind ein bisschen salzig
und aber Schoko drumrum.
Und die gibt es jetzt auch als Riegel. Schoko-Smash, Riegel,
alles aus Norwegen.
Mein Kopf war vorher als ein Riegel.
Vorher war es, naja,
kennst du,
boah, wie hießen die nochmal,
Bugels, kennst du Bugels? Kennst du Bugels?, wie hießen die nochmal, Buggels, kennst du Buggels?
Kennst du Buggels? Buggels sind so eine Art salzige Snacks. Ich meine nicht den Michels Scherz, ich weiß nicht mehr, was du mir gerade erklärst. Ich erkläre dir gerade den Schokosmeerschriegel. Dummle war ein Beispiel für die Verriegelung von Dingen, die nicht verriegelt gehören. So, und jetzt aber Buggels waren, also stell dir so eine Tüte Pombären vor, aber es ist so Windhosenform, so ein bisschen. Also so unten dünn wie so eine Eistüte. Ja? So, aber salzig. Mit Nougat drin. Nein, gar nichts drin, mit salzig. Und die sind geil, weil da kannst du zum Beispiel gut Frischkäse mitdippen, weil du hast ja wirklich diese Eistütenform, sind recht klein. Ah ja, kenn ich, kenn ich doch. Richtig lecker. Das als Snack für eine Party, wirklich immer ein bisschen Frischkäse in so einen Buckel, richtig geil. Und jetzt gibt es auch noch Buggels mit Schokoüberzug und das sind Schoko-Smash. So, und diese Schoko-Smash gibt es jetzt auch als Riegelform. Das heißt, du hast einen Schoko-R mit so einer Art ja fast schon Chip, salzigen Chip drin, super cross, super knusprig, richtig gutes Kauerlebnis, fast ein bisschen porös. Richtig geil. Was mir gerade eben angezeigt wird in meinen Algorithmen, ist so eine alte Handwerkskunst Süssigkeiten zu machen. Ja, so diese Bonbonsores, genau. Oder auch diese längere Schnüre oder manchmal wird das es wird etwas ganz anderes, als man denkt. Aber wo dann wirklich so ein alter, so gusseiserner Kessel kommt, mit ultraheissem Kram. Es hatte dann irgendwie 400 Degrees Fahrenheit. Und dann stürzen die den und es kommt auf so eine die dann auch immer so geile, glatte Auslagen, so Stein. Und es klebt null an einem Kessel. Es dampft so hoch. Es klebt da nicht dran. Es dampft und dann haben die diesen großen Edelstahlschieber und dann hat das das geile Kratzgeräusch, was man auch kennt wie so ein Pizzaschieber und dann durchmischen die das und das hat immer so eine gelblich-weisse Farbe und da rein kommt dann so Farbstoff und dann, ja, heute machen wir Cherry, machen so Cherry-Aroma rein und dann wird das durchmengt und dann wird das so rot und es wird immer ein bisschen kälter und dann, das ist absolut geil, diese Materialität ist so cool. Sowas von Glasblasen auch, diese heiße, glatte Masse, die man so kneten kann, aber du hast ein Time Limit, du weißt, du kannst das nicht ewig kneten und da ist die Handwerkskunst dann mit drin, weil du weißt, okay, wenn du es versaust, hast du am Ende und es darf nicht, Temperatur ist eine Frage, wie sehr kann es so machen und es ist ist auch eine Frage der Sauerstoffdichte. Und da haben die nämlich diesen Haken an der Wand. Ja, der Haken. Und das finde ich so eine geile, weil dieser Haken sagt irgendwie sowas wie Metzger oder sowas Brachiales, aber es geht darum, um Süßigkeiten, Bonbons zu machen. Du weißt, das wurde vor 500 Jahren auch schon mit so einem Haken gemacht. Die haben einfach einen Haken an der Wand und Der ist ein Monozweck-Haken. Was mich interessieren würde, in solchen Handwerksbetrieben gibt es ja oft so Lehrlinge, Initiationsrieten, Leute, die da mal anfangen. Und es gibt ja bestimmt im Moment so mein erster großer Zuckerkessel. Und da gibt es doch bestimmt in jeder Zuckergiesserei, in jeder Feinbäckerei gibt es doch bestimmt die Geschichte von, ich weiß noch damals, der Justus, der damals seinen ersten Kessel hatte und der ist komplett erstarrt und er war zu langsam und er hat es nicht geschafft, es in die Bonbonform zu bringen und am Ende war einfach wirklich so ein 40 Kilo Zuckerblock, der komplett erstarrt ist, steinhart, kannst du nicht mehr erwärmen. Und was machst du mit diesem Brocken? Muss der unglückliche Lehrling den mit nach Hause nehmen und als Schand mal mit sich tragen, weglecken? Jeder hat so einen Zuckerbrocken. Jeder Lehrling hat wahrscheinlich an irgendeinem Punkt mal einen Zuckerbrocken. Und dann gibt es wahrscheinlich die uralte Regel, bis du den nicht aufgeleckt hast, darfst du es nicht nochmal probieren. Als Strafe, dass du diesen riesigen Zuckerblock ruiniert hast, musst du ihn komplett weglecken. Und dann sieht man in jeder Zuckerbäckerei so traurige, weinende Lehrlinge, die mit einer ganz wunden Zunge an diesem riesigen Elefanten wulstig Körper, Zuckerörper-Zucker-Körper drin sind und versuchen das wegzuholen. Genau, und das ist so ein Chef, der sagt, kleiner Bursche, leck, leck, leck. Und am Fenster stehen dann so Passanten, weil es ist immer, und die dann sagen, oh, ein alter, ein alter schöner Betrieb, wo dann so ein Chef sagt zu seinem Lehrling, leck, leck, leck, leck, leck, cherry, immer nur cherry, da stehen sie am Fenster und sagen, oh, ein Zuckerbäcker. Und alle machen Fotos von deiner Schande. Das ist nämlich auch so, dass in diesen Videos dann oft ein Schaufenster da ist und eine alte Kopfsteinstrasse, wo dann die Touristen oder so, manchmal so Familien mit so Kindern, Kleinkindern, die sie so hochheben, damit sie reingucken kann. Und ich finde das tatsächlich super süss. Also diese Handwerke, ja so alte, so Manufaktur, Kunst, Zuckerkunst, Backkunst, toll. Was da für Zuckermengen draufgehen. Unfassbar. Wo kaufen die die? Aber sehr billig. Wo kaufen die den Zucker? Super billig Zucker. Ist Zucker billig? Ich glaube, Zucker ist extrem billig so. Zuckerrüben? Ich habe das mal durchgerechnet mit, das hat doch mal jemand fürgerechnet, die Popcorn-Maschine, die Popcorn-Lieferanten, dass wir gesagt haben, ah, wir wollen zu Hause einen Film gucken, lassen wir frisches Popcorn liefern und wir kommen vorbei mit dem Popcorn-Mobil. Und dann hat jemand tatsächlich irgendwie aus Spaß das mal wirklich wirtschaftlich aufgelistet. Du erzählst es so, als ob ich nicht mehr wüsste, was... Nee, ich muss das ja dem Zuhörer erklären. Und da hat jemand aufgelistet, was muss man alles einkaufen, Mitarbeiter kosten, würde sich das lohnen, für wie viel kann man so eine Packung Popcorn verkaufen? Und da stand auch drin Einkaufskreis Zucker und es war wirklich drei Cent. Ja genau, Zucker war extrem billig. Ganz verschwindend gering, völlig irrelevant, Zucker kostet nix. Da hat es Popcorn, ist auch super billig. Popcorn ist eh das Geilste, weil die Zutaten super billig sind und du es teuer verkaufen kannst. Mais ist nicht billig. Nicht mehr. Doch, sicher. Ganz billig. Ganz billig. Das ist doch sonst niemand. Das ist doch sonst niemand. Aber das fände ich wirklich mal gut. Ich mag Mais gar nicht. Mais in einem Salat zerstört für mich den Salat. Nein, oh nein. Mais zerstört für mich auch Burritos. Mais zerstört für mich manchmal Döner. Mais ist... Döner würde ich jetzt auch nicht. Horror, Horror. Nein, Mais und Erbsen überall rein. Das ist richtig geil. Jeder Salat Mais und Erbsen. Erbsen! Richtig gut. Schöner Tunafisch-Salad. Schön mit Erbsen und Mais und Dänen und Zwiebeln und Gürkchen. Boah, Tuna! Weg. Doch, Tuna und Mais, ganz fantastisch. Ganz fantastisch. Ich würde auch gerne so ein Handwerk beherrschen, ich habe es ja probiert mit Pizza, aber der Ofen ist nicht heiß genug und irgendwie finde ich meine Berufung nicht irgendwie. Ich dachte vielleicht so Sandwiches oder so, aber das ist ja tatsächlich noch meine... Das wird zu dir so passen, dass man so, Flurken, die macht die besten Sandwiches. Wenn man bei dem zu Hause ist, der hat immer so geiles Brot da, auch selber gemacht und schneidet es so frisch auf. Und dann machst du es in so einen Ofen und dann ist es so warm, dann hast du die besten Zutaten. Und dann, ah, das wäre geil für dich, das schenke ich dir auch zum Geburtstag. Ich weiß nicht genau, wann du Geburtstag hast, aber ich schenke dir das bald. Aber du hast diese Riesenfleischschneide-Dinger, die oft im italienischen Supermärkten hast hast. Da gibt es auch eine Seinfeld-Folge, wo die das plötzlich haben. Wo du selber so deinen Ausschnitt machen kannst. Und ich kaufe dann einfach ein Schweinebein, Schweinbein. Genau, so ein Schweinebein, schiebst du es so rein, und dann hast du wirklich so richtig viele so kleine geile Scheiben, und dann belegst du dann so wunderbar dick dieses Sandwich und dann machst du Salat rein und der hat Flotty macht immer die so Soßen dann selber, es passt so gut zu dir. Eine Sache, die ich nicht vergessen kann, die in meinem Kopf hängt wie ein Stück Popcorn am Gaumen nach einem herrlichen Kinobesuch. In den Brackets. Ich habe das mal vorgestellt, bei rbtv Home habe ich ein Video gezeigt von einem französischen Erfinder und in In Frankreich ist natürlich das Baguette ein grosses Ding, das Baguette. Aber wie belegt man Baguette richtig? Weil Baguette ist lang und wabbelig und wobbelig. Und wenn du da deinen Schinken und Käse und so, ist es schwer zu essen, weil überall lutscht die Soße raus und so. Schwierig. Deswegen hat jemand eine geniale Idee gehabt. Und zwar, du belegst nicht das Spaghetti, sondern du belegst
so einen Plastikstreifen.
So einen Plastikstreifen
mit Schinken, Käse,
Soßen. Und dann nimmst du das
Spaghetti, sägst nur oben
die Öffnung ab und dann schiebst
du diesen kompletten Plastikstreifen
in das Spaghetti rein,
drückst nach oben und ziehst den dann leer
wieder raus, sodass das Spaghetti
komplett belegt ist und
du es essen kannst, mit einer
Aber In das Spaghetti rein, drückst nach oben und ziehst den dann leer wieder raus, sodass das Spaghetti komplett belegt ist und du es essen kannst mit einer Öffnung oben, wie so ein Dürümfass, aber noch besser, weil du hast keine Öffnung. Oh, corndog, they are so good to me. Corndog, oh, corndog, they are so good to me.
They're good when they're old, they're good when they're fresh.
They're good when they're cold, they're good when they're fresh. They're good when they're cold, they're good when they're hot. Corn Dog, Corn Dog, they are ... Ja, perfekt. Und das finde ich eine richtig geile Erfindung. Aber das Geilste am Baguette ist ja, und da gibt es gar keine Diskussionen, das Weisse ... Die Krume. Innen drin. Die Krume. Hm? Nee. Doch, die Krume. Die Krume ist das Knäppchen. Nein, Brot besteht aus zwei Teilen, Kruste und Krume. Kruste ist das harte Außen, Krume ist das weiche Innene. Ja, ja, ja, ja. Aber Brotkrume sind doch die harten Flöckchen, wo Hänsel und Gretel den Weg markiert haben zur Hex. Nee, das ist das, was du rauspoolst, das Moos, das Weiche, das ist die Krume. Ja, ich meine das, was du meinst. Ich glaube, das ist falsch benannt, aber damit wir jetzt gerade über das Gleiche sprechen, das Weisse, Weiche innen drin. Okay. Das ist das Geilste. Man nennt das Krume. Das, wird das rausgeschnitten bei deinem Ding? Nee, nee, das ist natürlich noch ein Problem. Aber das klassische Baguette ist ja recht luftig innen. Also das kannst du ja nicht mit einem normalen Brotleit vergleichen, sondern das ist wirklich recht luftig und du kannst es wirklich relativ gut reinschieben. Und da vor allem denke ich mir, du kannst ja diese Spachteln, diese Schaufeln separat verkaufen. Weil Sandwich im Supermarkt ist immer blöd, weil du willst ja nicht diese sabligen, wobbligen dann in der Plastikverpackung. Ich hab nichts sabblig-wobblich. Ja, ich auch nicht. Aber du kannst dann irgendwie diese Spachtel einzeln kaufen, kaufst dir ein frisches Brot beim Bäcker, schiebst es rein und hast ein perfektes Sandwich. Und ich denke mir, das könnte wirklich ein Verhauffer da sein. Ganz ehrlich, ich bin da vielleicht, nämlich Banause, aber so ein Italian Footlong Sandwich bei Subway ist für mich das beste Brot für ein Sandwich. Absolut. Und ehrlich gesagt, ich bin Riesenfan der Franzosen. So ein Hoagie, so was Weiches, Schwammiges. Ich bin sehr frankophil, was so diese Genusskultur angeht, abends irgendwie nicht gross zu kochen, sondern einfach so ein Weissbrot zu haben, Wein zu haben, dann so ein bisschen so Käse, Salami am Tisch irgendwie und man ballert sich das so einfach rein und dieses, es hat so was super Geselliges für mich und sowas Tolles und dann raucht man noch am Tisch. Es hat sowas sehr so geniessen, ein bisschen auch so hat sowas Selbstzerstörerisches, weil der ganze Zeit auch Alkohol getrunken wird. Viel zu viel Käse, viel zu viel Fett, viel zu viel Salabe. Liebe ich, ich liebe das, aber das Baguette, da bin ich ein scharfer Kritiker, weil es ist ein bisschen zu hart, es ist oft zu alt, aber vielleicht habe ich auch noch nicht richtig gutes Baguette gegessen, aber es ist für mich nicht oft, es ist, also da wünsche ich mir fast dann eher so ein Subway, so ein bisschen labberig. Das stimmt schon, ja, Bag Rupfbrot, so du rupfst es ab und so einzelne Stücke oder so und belegt, es stimmt schon, es ist schwierig. Aber ich glaube, das ist wirklich eine gute Idee, dass du diese, weil alle Leute lieben Sandwiches, aber es ist immer so schwer zu handhaben. Das wäre so ein Hobby für dich, ich würde es lieben. Das ist schwierig. Und dann machst du so einen kleinen Foodtruck auf, Hey, da hast du auch einen Job. Ja, ich bin eh gerade auf der Suche, das stimmt. Ja, dann kannst du da mal so ein richtig gutes Sandwich haben. Blutten Sandwiches. Mit so richtig geiler Marmelade auch, mit so wie so Chutney-mäßig was Süsses drin, irgendwie, das dann so richtig schon seit Jahren rumsteht und dann so richtig brodelt. Aber das Ding ist, du bist ja, du, ich glaube nicht, dass du so ein Menschenfan bist.
Nee. Das Problem ist, bei deinem
Food-Sandwich-Truck,
dann bist du so ein bisschen wie der Soup-Nazi.
Ja, absolut. Die werden rumkommandiert,
leise, die müssen alle leise sein.
Wenn man sagt, ich weiß nicht, welches
Brot würden Sie denn empfehlen, sagst du, raus!
Raus, sofort raus.
Du hast die gesamte Zeit die Palette
vor dir, du weißt genau, was du bestellen kannst und wenn du es am Counter nicht weisst, wirst du wirklich sofort rausgeschmissen. Man muss passend zahlen, wenn da, wenn... Nur kontaktlos. Ich habe so einen Fuffi, hier habe ich... Raus, sofort raus. Wieso, ich habe... Raus, sofort raus. Wirklich. Und also, ich weiss, es ist trivial, aber so ein Hotdog ist eine Freude. Ist eine Faking-Freude. Mit Gurkchen und mit Röstzwiebeln. Hä, aber wir haben gerade noch von, du belegst deine eigene Pizza bis hin zu, du machst deine eigenen Sandwiches. Jetzt hast du einfach nur einen Hotdog-Stand. Aber es ist auch einfach geil. Du wirtschaftest dich halt selber gerade mega runter. Es ist auch einfach geil. Ich mag ja dieses Gurkige, senfige, röstzwiebelige so da drin. Ach, Leute. Es tut mir auch leid. Ich will euch jetzt nicht irgendwie alles schmackhaft machen, dass ihr direkt rechts ranfahrt und euch schon eine Pölzer holt irgendwie mit einer schönen dänischen Soße oder so. Aber es ist einfach lecker. Ich lieb's, ich lieb's, ich liebe Essen. Das Leben sollte sein, du wirst geboren, wachst auf, essen, essen, essen, du stirbst. Ja. Essen ist für mich hat so, ich habe auch jetzt aufgegeben übrigens, meine, ich hätte ja zwischendurch mal ein bisschen Ehrgeiz, sportlich zu sein. Ich wollte einmal in meinem Leben Sexpack haben, einmal in meinem Leben. Habe ich nicht mehr, diesen Wunsch habe ich nicht mehr, weil ich müsste so viel aufgeben, weil ich ziehe so viel Freude aus Essen und auch Maßlosigkeit, ungesundem Essen. Ja, Maßlosigkeit ist super gut, ja. Ja, und deswegen, ich möchte darauf nicht verzichten. Ich glaube, natürlich ist man ein bisschen unzufrieden, wenn man nicht die Figur hat, die man will oder so. Aber da muss man genau die Mitte finden zwischen, wo ist man am glücklichsten. Und ich glaube, bei mir ist der Regler schließt auf jeden Fall in Richtung maßlos essen.
Vor allem, es ist eine Grenze, die du auch locker überschreiten kannst, es sich aber trotzdem wie eine Grenzüberschreitung anfühlt.
Der Moment, als ich zu der Toblerone noch das Tender geholt habe, es war wirklich berauschend.
Weil es war wirklich ein, ich breche hier die Regel von ein Snack pro Einkauf, aber niemand kann mich fucking aufhalten. Ich möchte von dir ein Geheimnis haben. Was ist mit das Räudigste, was du jemals gemacht hast? Also hast du was belegt, was eh schon so fucking räudig ist mit etwas, was auch noch nicht... Ich habe aus dem Mülleimer gegessen, ich habe alles vom Boden gegessen, ich habe Dinge, die hinter die Heizung gefallen sind, gegessen.
Nee, aber so eine kulinarische so Nutella mit Erdnussbutter auf einem Löffel in den Mund geschoben.
Ich meine... Boah, ich glaube, es gab mal eine Schinken-Nutella-Phase, wo ich wirklich auch, also wie ich den Schinken so gerollt habe und dann in die Nutella rein und dann hergelöffelt habe da bin ich echt nicht stolz drauf aber das war eine geile Zeit aber das ist im Prinzip was du gesagt hast du wünschst dir herzhaftes mit was Süsses ich glaube so ein Schokoriegel wo du so einen schönen Schinken in der Mitte hast so einen schönen eingeringerollten Schinken und so eine Schokoladeumhellung. Beefy Chocolate. Ja. Beefy Chocolate. Ey, ich weiß nicht, wie Salami... Beefy Chocolate, ja. Das ist eigentlich nicht schlecht. Worum ist es dann nicht auch richtig gut konserviert? Müsste man das noch kühlen in Schinken? So eine Beefy in so einem Schokomantel. Ja. Oh, geil. Schlafrock. Beefy im Schokorock. Ach, das wäre möglich. Ich glaube, ich probiere das echt mal aus. Was ist Schlafrock? Das weiß ich nicht. Ich glaube, das ist so Blätterteig oder so. Ich weiß es auch nicht genau. Aber was ist das, warum Schlafrock? Ist das auch ein Kleidungsstück? Weil das den Körper so komplett bedeckt, dann weist du einmal komplett rum oder was? Weil das so ein Kleidungsstück ist, das ist wie so ein Kleid noch unten, oder weil du sonst nichts drunter hast oder so, ich weiß auch nicht genau. Ich weiß weder was ein Schlafrock ist, noch was ein sinnbildlicher Schlafrock ist, keine Ahnung. Okay, das Wort für uns irgendwo hin. Von Schlafen wirklich gar keine Ahnung, wirklich keine Ahnung, was da los ist. Wie geht es denn hinten eigentlich, du hast Armschienen bekommen? Termin im April, Neurologentermin im April. Ich erwarte ihn voller Hoffnung. Bis dahin immer noch hier und da Schwierigkeiten, wenn ich Dinge verkrampft halte. Also wenn ich Dinge wirklich klammere, verkrampft halte über längeren Zeitraum, dann habe ich schon noch Schwierigkeiten. Aber die Armschienen, ja, nehmen mir noch das letzte bisschen Freude, das ich noch übrig hatte. Aber gehört mittlerweile auch dazu, man gewöhnt
sich ja an die Fesseln.
Das war der Monthly Check-in.
Was krabbelt hier durch die Wand?
Ach du meine Güte, hier ist irgendwas
durch die Gegend gekrabbelt.
Das war rattig, ja?
Leben Ratten in der Wand eigentlich?
Ich warte auf dich.
Komm zu dir, ich warte.
Ich töte dich.
Habe ich doch mal geguckt, den zweiten Harry Potter Teil.
Ja.
Und zum ersten Mal geschnallt, dass der Basilisk nicht die ganze Zeit mit Harry spricht.
Ah, sondern?
Ah, mit seinen Opfern, was? Und Harry hört das nur und kann das verstehen. Oder? Also, das macht ja keinen Sinn. Harry ist ja kein Schlammblut. Nein, nein, genau. Ich hab den nicht mehr so ganz vor Augen, ehrlich gesagt, im Film. Das ist nicht so schlimm. Das ist okay. es passiert ja so viel gerade. Es ist ja so viel los. Ich weiß. Auch wirklich die Verkehrswende und so. Da muss man jetzt nicht unbedingt über Harry Potter 2 sprechen. Da musst du echt gucken, wo du bleibst. Jetzt mit den ganzen Anpassungen und Änderungen und so muss ich auch schauen, wo ich bleibe. Aber ich hoffe, wir konnten in dieser Folge ein bisschen Orientierung reinbringen. Mal wieder, zumindest in die kulinarische Welt. Das auf jeden Fall und ich hoffe auch, dass sich
einige Sprichwörter durchsetzen.
Die Kakaobohne im Schmetterlingshaus, glaube ich,
das ist schnippisch, das ist frech,
das kommt gut an. Schnippisch, ja.
Und unterstützt Florentin in seinem Foodtruck.
Das wäre mir wirklich wichtig.
Wie?
Dass er da mal hingeht, alle.
Geht da mal hin, weil
steht da die ganze Zeit, ich sehe den schon
am Obi-Parkplatz da stehen, ohne
Zuschauer. Mit dem Ding einzuparken
ist die fucking Hölle. Es sieht ja aus
wie ein riesiger Hotdog. Einfach diese
riesigen Stahlwurst.
Dann schiebst du irgendwann, weil dir alles egal ist, so wütend
die Autos vorne und hinten weg und dann
Pässe. Weil wirklich diese Würste sind
massiver Stahl.
Also wirklich massiver Stahl. Die sind wirklich acht Tonnen schwer, vorne und hinten auch nochmal. Diese Würstchen, ja. Warum? Die da rausstehen, damit es aussieht wie ein Hotdog. Die müssen komplett unterstützt werden. Also die sind fucking schwer, das Fahrgefühl ist eine absolute Katastrophe. Du fühlst dich immer, als würdest du auf Eis fahren, du schlackerst. Passt ein bisschen auf, wenn ihr den seht, einfach rechts ranfahren und warmen Blinkricht an. Und wenn ihr mich seht und ich schlacker schon auf der Strasse, lauft, versucht mich in die Seitplanke zu leiten. Opfert euer eigenes Fahrzeug und drückt mich in die Seitenplanke, damit ich überhaupt noch zum Stehen komme. Genau, bremst ihn aus, im Zweifel, bremst ihn, wenn ihr in den grossen Lkw fahrt, bremst Florent ihn aus, damit er mit seinem Hotdog-Mobil, was den TÜV, machen wir uns jetzt vor, noch nie ansatzweise bestanden hat. Nein, ich bin meistens manövrierunfähig, ich versuche mich von dem Strom des Verkehrs leiten zu lassen. Falls ihr mich seht auf der Autobahn, bitte helft mir, ich brauche wahrscheinlich Hilfe. Ja, und dann bist du irgendwann in so einem Obiparkplatz, wo man auch an dem Zustand des Fahrzeugs sieht, der kommt im Leben nicht mehr weg. Der ist komplett voll durch den Zaun. Er steckt im Obi drin, die Wurst steckt so, das sieht auch ein bisschen obszön aus. Ja, das stimmt. Diese Wurst vorne steckt im Obi drin und da ist er jetzt und da verkauft er, guckt aber auch zur falschen Seite raus. Also leider Gottes ist die Öffnung des Fahrzeugs... Genau, man muss einmal außen rumgehen, so am Zaun vorbeizwängen. Du musst dir vorstellen, das ist wie so ein Bauhaus, also der Baumarkt ist wie so ein L und er ist so am Rand reingefahren, aber die Öffnung ist leider zur Seite, wo noch gewandt ist. Genau, wo man niemanden sieht. Und du kriegst so kaum dieses, oben vorne diese Tür auf. Ich musste ein bisschen den Zaun wegtreten, damit ich überhaupt die Klappe aufbekomme. Und da muss man sich so durchschieben. Ja, es ist nicht ideal, aber wie gesagt, schaut gerne mal vorbei, also die Hot Dogs sind lecker und es lohnt sich auf jeden Fall, ja. Naja, wir sehen uns ja dann am Stand, haut rein Stefan, schön, dass du auch ab und zu vorbeikommst. Haut rein, Flotin, vielen Dank für die Folge, vielen Dank für dich, vielen Dank an die Anwesenheit. Dankeschön, vielen Dank an Chris für das Intro, haut rein, macht's gut, wir sehen uns.
Und alles Gute.
Dann zum Glück, ja, danke, ey, und sorry auch nochmal und dann sehen wir uns ja nächste Woche wieder.
Tschüss, Lies, äh, tschau, macht's gut, danke, tschüss, hüdel, hüdel, hüdel, hüdel, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh, höh,